we defined the equation of the plane can
train containing the straight line they
give us the equation right over here and
this plane has to be perpendicular to
the plane containing the straight lines
this thing right over here x over 3 is
equal to Y over 4 is equal to Z over 2
and also it has the line x over 4 is
equal to Y over 2 is equal to Z over 3
now just to visualize this properly let
me draw the planes so the first plane
the first plane in question that we need
to find the equation of let me draw it
let me draw it like this so we need to
find the equation of this plane and I'm
going to try to do this whole problem
using vector notation because it's
easier in my mind to manipulate vectors
in a way that you can find perpendicular
vectors and equations for planes there's
other ways that you could do this
problem so we need to find the equation
of this plane right here we need to find
the equation now we know this plane
contains this line and this line if we
look at it right over here it contains
the point 0 0 0 if x and y and z are all
equal to 0 then all sides of these
equations are 0 so it contains the point
0 0 0 so 0 0 0 or you could even view it
as it contains the position vector 0 0 0
it also contains the point 2 3 4 because
if X is 2 y is 3 and Z is 4 then all of
these are going to be equal to 1 so let
me draw that right over here so it also
contains the point or the position
vector we could say 2 2 3 4 so if we
wanted to just draw this line to point
specify the line so this line would look
this line would look like that but if we
wanted to think about a vector that this
plane contains it would be the vector
that goes from 0 0 0 to 2 3 4 so it
would be this vector right here which
really is the position vector 2 3 4 and
I'm going to write an IJ K notation just
to make it clear that this is a vector
so this vector that lies in the plane in
question is the vector 2i I'll write it
over here
2i plus 3j plus plus 4 K I just wrote it
in unit vector
I'll say eh I'll call this vector a
vector a is equal to that and I'll write
a over here now we need to figure out
the equation we need to figure out the
equation of this line and the best way
to do it or at least the way my brain is
telling me to do it is if I could find
if I could find a nother if I can find
another vector in this plane then I can
find a normal vector to this plane and
then using a normal vector and some
arbitrary other vector on this plane
I can then figure out the equation of
the line because the normal vector
dotted that arbitrary other vector has
to be equal to zero now if none of that
makes any sense maybe as we go through
the problem it will make more sense so
what I'm going to do what I'm going to
do is use this use these other lines
really the other vectors that are
implicitly defined by these lines to
figure out to figure out another vector
in this plane over here so let me let me
draw what I'm talking about that might
be easier so let me draw this other
plane and I'll draw it in white and this
other plane also contains 0 0 0 actually
both of these lines over here contain 0
0 0 so let me draw it over here so this
other plane I think what I just said if
I do it step by step it'll make a lot
more sense so the other plane that's
when it comes vertically above this
plane and it goes vertically below the
plane as well and we see this the plane
that contains these two lines is
perpendicular to this they're
perpendicular to each other and we need
to find the equation of the yellow plane
now this blue line over here it contains
the point 0 0 0 and the point 3 4 2 same
logic that we got to get to this point
if this is 3 this is 4 this is 2 they
all equal 1 the quality the equation
holds so let me just draw some arbitrary
place so 3 4 2 and I want to be clear
I'm not have I haven't even defined the
coordinate axes we don't know what angle
we're looking at this from this is just
for visualization purposes so this line
right over here I could draw it would
look something like this it would look
something like that
it sits on that white plane we could do
the same thing for this magenta line the
magenta line also contains 0 0 0 but it
contains the point 4
two and three so let me just draw it
over here so four two three so that's
the magenta line the magenta line and
you wouldn't even see it if this was
transparent you would see the line it
would just keep going down like that now
I'm going to attempt to explain how I'm
going to tackle this problem again I'm
going to use vectors defined that are
implicitly defined by this blue line and
this magenta line I'm going to take the
cross product of those two vectors to
find a vector that is normal that is
normal to this entire white plane and
that vector has to sit in this
perpendicular plane and then I can use
that vector and vector a to figure out a
normal vector for this plane and then
I'll be able to figure out the equation
of the plane let me just do it instead
of keep trying to so what's a vector
what are two vectors that sit in this
white plane well the point zero zero
zero the position vector zero zero zero
and the position vector four to three is
in this plane so look so the so the
vector the vector I'll call that B the
vector B is equal to 4 I plus 2j plus 3k
is also in this white plane and you're
really I'm just subtracting I'm just
subtracting this position vector from
that position vector to get this
position vector which clearly sits in
the plane this vector starts at the
origin goes to four two three this plane
contains the origin is clearly sitting
in that plane and by that same logic I
could figure out a vector it's actually
the position vector itself sits on this
plane so this is the vector I'll call
that C is equal to three I plus four J
plus two K the fact that everything is
at the origin kind of simplifies it the
position vectors themselves sit on the
plane if if if the if the if this wasn't
centered at the origin we wouldn't we
wouldn't be able to do that we would
have to subtract between these two
vectors or between two other points to
actually get vectors on the plane but
with that out of the way I could take
the cross-product I could take the cross
product of B and C so I could take the
cross product of B and C and that will
give
us some vector that'll give us some
vector that is that is perpendicular to
both B and C which means that is
perpendicular or it's normal to this
entire white plane which means it must
sit in this yellow plane so I need to
find I want to find a normal vector that
in the yellow plane just like that let's
call that let's call that vector D so
the vector D is going to be equal to
this and so the cross product of B and C
is just the this is how I remember it's
the determinant of you take i j k and we
explain this in a lot more depth in the
linear algebra playlist but it's the
determinant of that the next row is is
vector B so it's 4 2 & 3 and then the
next row is the vectors 4 is the is
vector C so 3 4 and 2 3 4 and 2 and so
this is going to be equal to this is
going to be equal to let's think about
it so for I you cross out that column
that row it's 2 times 2 minus 3 times 4
so that's 4 minus 12 so it's negative 8
negative 8 times I negative 8 times I
minus we're going to have to swap signs
you go plus minus plus when you're
taking the determinant so you ignore the
J so it's 4 times 2 4 times 2 is 8 minus
3 times 3 which is negative 1 so this
would be a negative 1 here but I already
have a negative out there so it's going
to be plus 1 plus 1 J and then finally
the K you cross out that row that column
4 times 4 is 16 16 16 16 minus 6 is 10
so plus plus 10 let me make sure I got
that right so the first one I always
have to make sure so I I got yep 4 minus
12 is negative 8 then J cross that out 4
times 2 is 8 minus 9 is negative 1 but
the J is a negative so that's right and
then K 4 times 4
sixteen sixteen minus six is ten so that
looks right so plus plus 10k so this
vector right here this is the vector D
this is the vector D I just figured it
out now if we take the cross product of
D and vector a the vector that was you
can kind of view it as lying along this
line over here then we will get a vector
that is normal to this plane then we can
get a vector we could get a vector that
is normal to this play we could call
that vector and for normal that is
normal to the yellow plane and it would
actually sit in the white plane so let's
figure that and we'll see you'll see in
a few steps probably in the next video
why that is actually useful so let's
let's take let's take let's find what D
cross so if I take the cross product D
cross D cross a D cross a is going to be
equal to our normal vector is going to
be our equal to our normal vector which
is equal to same thing i j k we're going
to take d which is negative 8 1 10 and
take the cross of that and the vector a
which is 2 3 4 2 3 4 and we will get and
actually i'll continue this in the next
video just so that I don't make these
videos too long